these words are the title of my
presentation followed by my name
now you'll note it doesn't say bye Jason
Roberts because in early 21st century
San Francisco you don't need to do that
it's implied
now I just spent 15 seconds telling you
the obvious and here's why I am a writer
I'm a writer of Books mostly non-fiction
books mostly historical non-fiction
books which means I'm also an historian
kind of deal with the past now there are
a lot of challenges in terms of dealing
with the past
um they're texts that are lost there are
texts that are biased uh translations
that are wrong some things that can't be
translated like this is the Voynich
manuscript and there's lots of lost
content
but the worst thing is that encapsulated
in the phrase it goes without saying
so much history actually is lost to us
not because the historical record is
gone but because it was never in this
Oracle record in the first place
why waste useful papyruses or anything
like that to say what's completely
obvious what's common knowledge these
are Roman dodecahedrons these are these
12-sided metal and stone objects that we
find in hundreds of ancient Roman sites
throughout Europe what are they we don't
know
we have plenty of theories they might be
fishing weights they might be musical
instruments they might be early Dungeons
and Dragons but the the point is that we
have to guess because the Romans they
were so commonplace that the
instructions and how to use them were
commonplace here's garam now the Romans
loved jerem it's this condiment they
used it on everything it was their
mayonnaise and mustard and salt and
pepper all put together their entire
economy was built around it but we don't
know what it was except for the fact
that it seems to have involved fish
now we have plenty of Roman recipes in
fact the word recipe is Latin for first
you take like first you take a fish but
of the hundreds if not thousands of
recipes none of them is for the most
common object
here's another thing um they're in the
Bible itself there's this character
called the disciple whom Jesus loved
which you think would be kind of a big
deal and Jesus thought it was a big deal
he sat next to him in the Last Supper in
fact at some point Jesus puts his head
in his lap he's a very important person
he was adopted by the Virgin Mary he's
the one who discovers the resurrection
he's granted a mortality and he's one of
the authors of the Bible but for the
other authors of the Bible they thought
nobody needed to say who he was his
identity went without saying
now here's a big question why are they
called buggies when you think about it
that's kind of a strange name for a
horse and carriage so I thought it might
be a very interesting answer so I posed
it to the champion of interesting
answers chat GPT
now it says it says here um that um it
originally referred to a frightening
Specter hob Garden Goblin blah blah blah
refers to a small lightweight vehicle
associated with blah blah blah the point
is that that was all wrong
I asked the question because I knew that
there is no answer to it and when I went
and then it actually started
hallucinating the answer now
for that reason I believe I need to
propose something called DOI the
depository of obvious information
for future Generations let's create
let's say the unsaid that idea that it
goes without saying is not necessary
because honestly uncommon knowledge
it becomes common knowledge and vice
versa most importantly here's a question
what is the FAA definition of flight see
some things aren't quite trivial it
turns out there is no definition for
flight there's a definition for flight
time which begins when when a vehicle
pushes forward for the purpose of flight
but there is no actual definition of
flight which is interesting because it
turns out that you know qualified Pilots
need certain degrees of flight time your
body could have 100 degrees of flight
time but actually no five minutes of
actual flight or here's another example
is sudden death I looked on Wikipedia I
looked everywhere on the internet
there's no definition that describes
that no actual death is involved
and in fact I asked this question what
does the phrase my Ultimate Team
encountered sudden death mean
something went wrong ah
if it's going to confuse AI it's going
to confuse future Generations
so you know this is the thing confusion
is actually useful instead of trying to
gloss over these things instead of
having a I hallucinate the answers how
about it identifies where those gaps of
knowledge are it could work with us to
identify those gaps and basically create
the depository of obvious information so
join me won't you join me in saying
maybe you don't know what I mean maybe
you want to
maybe we can bridge that Gap thank you
very much